Es wird immer klarer wir haben ein gigantisches
plastikmüll probleme auf unserer erde plastik ist mittlerweile überall in unseren körpern am
Straßenrand in der luft wie ich letztens berichtet habe in den wäldern und in den tiefen des ozeans doch es gibt viele kreative ideen
Um, gegen die risiken plastik berger anzugehen oder sie zukünftig sogar ganz
Zu vermeiden hier die vier besten lösungsideen, um unsere erde vielleicht doch noch von dem gigantischen
Umwelt killer plastik, zu erlösen herzlich willkommen bei klick zum science fiction. Und danke für den themenvorschlag bei %
Alleine in den meeren schwimmen schätzungen zufolge, mehr als fünf millionen
Plastikteile das ist eine zahl mit 18 nullen
unvorstellbar, und
Auf unseren tellern landet der plastikmüll
Täglich aus der luft in jeder mahlzeit die wir zu uns, nehmen sind rund 100. Mikro plastikteilchen
Ein forschungsteam von der harry atwater university in edinburgh untersucht den wieviel. Micro plastikteilchen während einer
Mahlzeit aus der luft auf dem teller landen es waren 100
Und damit sind 70.000 im jahr die wir essen es ist wirklich
Ein riesenproblem aber wie kann es gelöst werden, erste idee walking
Joggen, und sammeln diese idee ist vor allem für diejenigen unter euch gedacht die
Sowieso gerne sport machen und sich dabei vielleicht sogar. Noch vorstellen können auch der umwelt etwas gutes
zu tun blogging setzt
Sich zusammen aus dem wort doping und dem schwedischen begriff blog also sammeln die idee. Joggen gehen, und dabei
Müll aufheben sammeln, und am ende entsorgt tatsächlich in schweden. Eine trendsportart die es mittlerweile
Auch in immer mehr deutschen städten gibt und was soll ich sagen wenn
Ihr euch blickt in die knie geht und euch dann nach dem einsammeln des mülls wieder aufrichtet trainiert
Er damit noch mehr muskeln als beim einfachen. Laufen aber achtung nicht zu schnell machen dann fällt man. Nämlich automatisch
Um macht das haben wir immer in der grundschule gemacht ist auf jeden fall lust sich aber auch gefährlich kann, man
Sich böse. Verletzen zurück zum thema zweite idee die weltmeere vom plastik befreien die bilder sind mehr als erschreckend in den
Ozean tragen gigantische müllteppich, um die meere davon, zu befreien gibt es viele. Einzelne gute ideen
Und aktionen denn fest steht mit fang teppichen wird es ewig dauert deswegen wurde jetzt beispielsweise. Eine bis. Zu zwei kilometer lange
Schlauchförmige boje entwickelt die den. Müll einsammelt das tolle. Daran sie treibt völlig autonom mehr und schiffe holen den von
Ihr gesammelten müll ab lebewesen werden nicht gefährdet, denn die werden unter die
Barrieren gedrückt die elektrischen, komponenten werden von solarenergie betrieben und somit ist die erfindung
Komplett klimaneutral ab 2020 sollen sie in allen weltmeeren. Eingesetzt werden bis dahin läuft. Noch das crowdfunding von
Roshan, cleanup zudem gibt es einen finanziellen zuschuss der niederländischen regierung eine weitere idee in diesem. Zusammenhang ist das sogenannte
screening das modell erinnert an einem überdimensionalen
rochen der 409 und 400 meter
Misst und an drei seiten geschlossen ist die idee stammt von einer architektin aus aachen die damit auch schon, einige preise gewonnen hat die
Konstruktion soll durch drahtseile am meeresboden befestigt werden so dass die offene. Seite zur strömung zeit durch den
Austausch von tiefen, und oberflächenwasser wird plastik tatsächlich bis in eine tiefe von 30 metern befördert plastik
Und plastik partikel werden so gefiltert und können recycelt werden
Und in computermodellen hat diese technik tatsächlich schon gut funktioniert. Im raum steht jetzt
Noch die frage der finanzierung. Dritte idee plastik fressende bakterien schon vor zwei. Jahren machte, ein
Forschungsteam aus japan eine aufregende entdeckung in der nähe einer recycling fabrik für pet-flaschen
Entdeckten sie bakterien die sich hauptsächlich vom plastik ernährten sie nannten sie in eller sagt. Karin s
201 strich 11 6 und ließen sie unter laborbedingungen einen feinen plastik film fressen. Dafür brauchten die bakterien
60 wochen also leider viel zu lange, um, gegen den. Müll im meer an zu kämpfen doch auch britische. Und amerikanische
Forschungsteams hatten derweil mikroben entdeckt die sogar auf dem plastikmüll im ozean siedeln und den kunststoff auffressen
Wie genau, das passiert und ob sie dabei gegebenenfalls giftstoffe freisetzen ist allerdings
Noch nicht bekannt doch trotzdem gibt es die idee müll fressende
Mikroben auf das plastik im meer auf dem plastikmeer auszusetzen doch das ist mehr als umstritten denn schließlich
Sind die folgen auf das ökosystem. Je mehr völlig unklar vierte idee
Sinnvolle alternative bioplastik aus organischem abfall ja endlich mal
Das problem bei der wurzel packen über diese idee hatten wir hier bei klick zum science. Und fiction berichtet und sagt geht es
um
Einen wirklich eine sinnvolle alternative zu den umweltschädlichen plastik bioplastik nämlich je gestellt aus organischem abfall also
Beispielsweise essensresten. Müll aus dem landwirtschaftlichen bereich oder auch kartons die
dann, kompostiert werden mit dieser idee will das unternehmen fuß
bioplastics dem gigantischen plastik problem unserer erde den kampf ansagen
Und gleichzeitig vielleicht auch unser leben revolutionären in einer eigens von ihnen entwickelten kompostieranlage
Laufen chemische prozesse ab und am ende gibt es. Dann. Ein abwasser dass sehr viele fettsäuren enthält durch den
einsatz von backen werden genau diese
Fettsäuren in poley hydroxyl fettsäuren. So genanntes micro verwandelt das ist eine. Zähe und milchige. Masse die, man
Dann, zur verpackung pressen kann das tolle an diesem. Konzept anders als andere. Hersteller werden, hierbei
Keine, extra chemikalien oder extra gezüchtete pflanzen benötigt und wenn die produzierten produkte nicht mehr gebraucht werden nimmt die firma sie zurück
Um wiederum neues bio plastik daraus herzustellen doch selbst wenn es in der landschaft oder im wasser landet ist es dort noch lange nicht
So gefährlich und schädlich wie das konventionell hergestellte plastik denn nach angaben der anderson brüder
Verrottet ist einfach auf natürliche art und weise vergleichbar mit laub zudem sei
Ihr verfahren co2 neutral brauche wenig energie und wasser kohlendioxid wird bei ihrem kompost. Ihr system zunächst sogar
gebunden wenn die produkte dann später kompostiert werden
Wird es allerdings wieder freigesetzt aber nicht nur in den usa sondern auch in deutschland wird an ähnlichen
konzept getüftelt cool würde ich mal sagen
Und jetzt gibt es zehn euro für jeden ungelogen meine whatsapp community hat mich gebeten einen special deal
Auszuhandeln und ich habe. Ihm bekommen bei dem vom stiftung warentest am besten
Getesteten cashback portal gibt es zehn euro plus noch. Ein sonder cashback das ganze bekommt der am sonntag wenn
ihr euch hier bei whatsapp anmeldet einfach draufklicken
Übervater zudem vom meer noch vor einem anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
um
Am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
Glocke vergessen hier geht es war damit. Dafür auch draufklicken
erschreckend, wir essen unmengen micro plastik bis dann
bleibt dran